so often we think that the greatest
basketball player of all time is Michael
Joyner the greatest entrepreneur of all
time is Elon Musk or some of these other
guys or the greatest businessman or the
greatest anything are the ones that we
know about the greatest actor of all
time like right now is you know Leonardo
DiCaprio or no it's uh who's the guy
Johnny Depp or maybe it's who the
multi-dimensional actors we talked about
you know Hardy or some of these we think
they're the best actors in the
marketplace but I will tell you I
believe in my opinion the greatest
talents of all time who would have been
better than Michael Jordan who would
have been better than any of the
greatest actors we've ever seen who
would have been greater than any of the
greatest entrepreneurs we've ever seen
are the ones who gave up at one point
and because at one point they gave up no
one in the world knows about it look
right now we have around what was the
number you told me earlier Mario on how
many people follow our content over half
a million people follow the content on a
monthly basis around the world from
about 200 different countries and it's
half a million people weren't following
Patrick wait David ten years ago this
me thirteen years ago nobody knew
Patrick wait David wasn't a lot of times
you know the whole part of you becoming
whoever you want to become in life your
reasons may be different things many of
you follow this content are not
necessarily just in the same industry
I'm a part of you're doing a lot of
different things but the principles are
similar and so for me when I think about
my own story I think about one story I
have a lot of every single day I run
when I decided to get into sales every
day I wanted to quit sales when I worked
at Bally Total Fitness because I was
terrible in sales listen I was the worst
sale if you write a book the worst
salesman of all time my face should be
on the cover of it that's how bad I was
in sales I was terrible can sell anybody
when I was working at Bally's it was my
first sales job I had and then from
there when I decided to take the leap of
faith from w2 into going to being a
business owner where it's ten ninety
nine to one where you make money it's
based on what you sell something you
make money if you don't sell this thing
you don't make money and then you go
into the 1099 space and that's the day
when it's scary because every day you
come home you don't sell
and guess what you're at a business that
day if you don't sell a policy if you
don't sell a home if you don't sell an
insurance and annuity ate whatever it is
a membership you you are not in business
that day you you're not making money
that day so there's a certain sense of
do I want to just go back or do I just
want to give up and go back and do this
and there was one time breaking point
I'll give you the exact date the exact
location the exact feeling pain
everything about it it is December 31st
2002 December 31st 2002 and in
California La Studio City you know when
you go to Universal Studios at that time
we serve Universal Studio we have
nothing we have no money so we can't
even force to go to Vegas my buddy and I
so we went out and everyone's going out
let's go to a nightclub let's go to
clubs I have nothing to my name nothing
I had a couple thousand dollars of
payments that was sent out uh that
didn't end up hitting the payments
because B of a my credit card was over
the limit they ended up taking all the
money out of my checking account to pay
the bills I have nothing going on in my
account I have is zero going on in my I
don't have money to buy gas I don't have
money to buy an in-and-out burger
double-double but my friend and I were
both 220 pound of guys at that time we
go by this in-n-out burger it's 11:50 we
go to the back side it's an alley you go
all the way up it's like this we parked
the car my Ford Focus I haven't made a
payment for a couple months two or three
months and we're in this car and we're
listening to who Ryan Seacrest is a Ryan
Seacrest is that the rhein secrets right
and we're listening to Ryan Seacrest for
the countdown we take the in and out we
split as we had some change we split it
he gets to half I get half we're eating
the in and out and I am literally in the
car thinking to myself while I'm
listening to the countdown with Ryan
Seacrest tears are coming down my eyes
I'm emotional telling myself is this
really it like is this truly it is this
really what life is all about so this is
what life is supposed to be about it's
supposed to be this difficult it's
supposed to be someone knowing it's
supposed to be this but we don't even
have a name
any money to go out and celebrate New
Year's this is how it supposed to be
when your dad is in a hospital because
of heart attacks because you can't
afford to help your dad out with a
couple thousand dollars here and there
is this how life is truly supposed to be
you're supposed to be miserable stressed
out about money for the rest of your
life watching all these other people
having their dreams come true and deep
down inside you're thinking to yourself
can I ever be like that person does that
person have certain special god-given
ability that I don't have am I really
that terrible am I really that not
talented and not gifted am I really that
horrible at what I do is that really
really what it is and this countdown is
going down and I hear 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2
1 and the countdown happens there is no
joy nothing there's no joy there's no
feeling of excitement inspiration none
no joy in the belly at all whatsoever
and that night I made a decision and I
said this is going to be the last year
ever that I go into another you're not
excited not being at a place where I'm
excited about my year I'm not gonna let
this happen anymore
it was so much sheer frustration anxiety
agitation frustrate everything combined
together was in me that night and for
whatever reason I couldn't even wait to
go to I didn't want to go to sleep I
could care less about what we're gonna
do that and I just wanted to get back to
work the next thing start reading
working on myself develop and selling :
following up going and prospect and
talking I just there was a certain level
of urgency and I will tell you I will
tell you hearing a lot of my friends
will tell you this as well my eyes
changed from December 31st 2002 to
January 1st 2003 completely changed boom
flicker change different eyes overnight
my eyes changed I went to the guy that
was droopy my eyes were you could tell
when somebody doesn't really know where
they're going to look at their eyes
you're looking all over the place boom
clear we're making this happen the
following year I said this year for New
Year's I'm gonna go to New York City I'm
gonna celebrate the ball being dropped
I'm going to stay at the hotel on
Manhattan right in front of the ball I'm
gonna go shopping at Saks Fifth Avenue
with $5,000 of clothes this is what I'm
going to do that's what happened to
following your defy
rolling gear I said one of my guys his
dream was to go to Guatemala to go out
there and see Tikal and he wanted to
give all these food and Bibles all this
other stuff to him and I'm running a
financial services business at that time
and he's one of the agents that I'm
mentoring so I want to go to Guatemala
we went to Guatemala and this became a
tradition and every year it was more and
more and more and more excitement about
what is possible that you and I can
contribute to the world with the limited
time that we have in the world what you
and I can do to contribute to the world
and all this goes back to ten reasons
why you should never give up and I'm
going to get right into it specific
reasons why you should never give up and
and I hope when you're watching this
message you realize whatever point you
are in your life you're never as bad as
you think you are and you're never as
great as you think you are believe me
you're typically right in the middle but
you have so many abilities that no one
will ever find out because so often
people give up right so let's talk about
the ten reasons why you should never
give up number one it's very easy to
find a reason to quit no matter what any
anything you're going through the
easiest thing to find is to find a
reason to quit I hear so many people
that say things like you know the other
day I was thinking about if if I should
be an entrepreneur now if I should be in
the financial industry now if I should
do this business if I should do this and
then I asked God for a sign and I was
going through and I saw a poster and it
said this and I took it as it's time for
me to quit I watch this movie and in the
movie this person quit and it was a sign
that meant I need to quit no what that
means is the only things your lenses are
looking for they're looking for signs
for you to could you've already quit
you've already quit you've already given
up this decisions already been made here
to give up because the difference in a
mind is what you look at every single
thing as to what oh that's why I want to
make it oh that's why I can do it oh
that's why great things are coming oh my
god this is so glycerol science degree
so its optimism that you're attracting
to yourself because if you can't look
for reasons to cut your going to find
millions of reason to quit and give up
on anything you're doing number two when
you quit you send a message that you
never thought you could make in the
first place universe that's that's the
thing when you could you send a message
to the world that you never really
thought you were going to make in the
first place you never thought we're
going to make in the first place you
never thought you were going to make in
first it was just something you tried
but it's you know I honestly didn't
think that I was going to make this and
everyone knows everyone your friends
family will be very nice to you they'll
be very gentle generally there'll always
be one person that's going to be very
brutal brutal with you hey what happened
with that thing I thought you were going
to be a millionaire huh
I thought you were going to be an
incredible entrepreneur I thought you
were going to buy yourself a Ferrari I
thought you're going to go out and buy a
big house what happened how you realize
you realize that doesn't happen with us
and you bought them these people told
you whatever they told you and you
believed it boom your message to them is
I never really thought I was going to
make in the first place
three believe it or not some people will
be glad when you give up this is a very
strange thing it's a very difficult
thing because most people don't
understand why would a friend or a
cousin want me to give up why would a
friend or a cousin be glad I gave up
well let me explain to you why that is
you got five friends five people you
hang out with right five friends all
come from the same community you went to
the same place everybody came from a
family where they saw the same drugs
same girls same parties same alcohol
same 40s mickey's whatever you guys
drink whatever forties you did whatever
clubs you went to whatever night comes
you whatever girls you chase everyone's
the same everyone was a knucklehead you
played sports basketball baseball you
saw the fights you saw who got knocked
out who fought who all the friends fight
everybody you know everyone stories
right which group broke up with who and
which girl left for the other friend all
this other stuff right guys or girls
well everybody's kind of living an
average life and it was making somewhere
between thirty to sixty thousand dollars
here and then one of the friends decides
to go out and become an entrepreneur and
all of a sudden that person starts who
was a person nobody expected that person
to do anything with big with their lives
now he's making or she's making 100 200
300 400 500 600 thousand dollars per
year and they're contributing all over
the world they're being you know
recognition all this other stuff the
other four who are still at 60 70 80 100
hundred fifty thousand I'm using a
number because that's a measuring thing
money is purely a measuring stick that's
all there is it has nothing to do with
personality to a measuring stick so the
other person is still content at 60 70
80 and they're they're not really happy
that this person is not making six
hundred you really think they're glad
about this you really think people are
truly glad about this sometimes it's the
strangest things and some people watch
Sensei Pat that's not fair for you to
think that it's a law
you know what laws I don't fight with
this is called a law of gravity
law of reciprocity love attraction there
are so many laws there's a law where
there are people in your life that don't
want to see you leave the comfort zone
and all of a sudden go out and have your
dreams come true that makes them feel
like they could have done the same as
well but they didn't and you don't
necessarily make them look good so
that's why sometimes some people have a
hard time when their friends and family
create rumors about them they say why
would my friend say this why would my
cousin say this why would say all this
other stuff I'm about to do another
video that talks about the 10 criticisms
entrepreneurs normally get people people
don't some why that happens it's part of
the game number 4 you'll never know what
would happen if you stuck it out can you
imagine like living life I want you to
visualize this you're 82 years old okay
it's your funeral
you're 82 years old it's your funeral
and you've been in the hospital for a
month okay your funeral is about to come
up you know you got a month to live
doctor tells you and you're in your bed
and you have your family friends
everybody there with you and there are
many quiet moments with yourself that I
don't know what you're going to be
thinking about but I'm assuming you're
going to be thinking about the moments
with people you love the most
wife kids those thoughts are going to
have but I'm sure there's going to be a
quiet moment as well when you're gonna
say and maybe again at that time when
you're dying I mean some when you're
done you can have a lot of thoughts
about God you know even Chris Hitchens
who didn't believe in God the closer he
was getting to dying he was thinking
about it even more and more and more
about the existence even though he
denied and says I still don't believe
there's a god we're gonna have those
conversations but one of the
conversations that's probably gonna take
places man did I give everything with
this eight years that I had could I have
done more may could I have contributed I
have become a better better father did I
use my talents did I really make a
difference there already make an impact
the way I could help you have that
conversation that's a tough one to face
because it's you against you it's not
anybody else and a challenge with that
is we rarely think about that
situation why because you're watching
this you're 22 you're thinking you'll
never be 80 you know you're watching
this you're 38 you think got plenty of
time to go but the reality is like this
we're 80 hands never lie I say this all
the time if you look at your hands you
can tell someone's age by their hands I
can always see somebody can have very
nice skin here but you look at their
hand you say yup he's 48 can tell from
the hands yup he's 39 yup he's 58
this doesn't lie this is going like this
quickly it's going like this time is
flying like you wouldn't believe
do you really want to have the life to
look back and say what would it happen
if I would have given everything I had
what if I build that life number number
five ways you never give up the
consequences of giving up or quitting
are quite a lot higher than sticking it
out a lot of times we have this pain
that man I would rather go home and
watch the game tonight I don't really
want to work today it's Saturday I'm not
supposed to be working on Saturday I
have a meeting on Sunday do you read
each I don't want to work on Sunday I
should be home and you're not watching
everybody else is watching Super Bowl I
shouldn't be out here selling and you
feel sorry that maybe you're working too
hard you know I should this is too much
you know honestly this life bun is
really not that important money is
really not that important it's not it's
not that important I'm just gonna I'm
better off while going getting a job
from 9:00 to 5:00 and just really living
a reg that's what I'm gonna be doing I'm
not going to go for the whole thing and
then you don't see the consequences but
then later on when you realize we want
to school school is expensive you have
two kids and it's very expensive diapers
are expensive marriage is expensive
weddings are expensive anniversaries are
expensive Christmas is expensive
holidays are expensive birthdays are
expensive clothes expensive lifestyle is
expensive car insurance is expensive
mortgage is expensive that is expensive
everything is expensive then you realize
there's a big difference if I'd be
making 220 right now versus making
$28,000 here right now $38,000 here
right now there's a big difference with
that so the consequences of you given up
is by far by far bigger than your
sticking it out and actually making it
happen for yourself six when you quit
you set a mental precedent that you quit
again
quitting is a very simple habit you do
you'll do it again quitting is a very
simple habit by the way fighting
throwing winning is also habit just so
you know that there's a reason why they
said that guy's a fighter I don't know
what's going to happen you just don't
want to fight that guy he's a fighter he
may not be the best rebel he's a fighter
you don't you don't give up that that
guy's still a fighter it's a habit as
well giving up is absolutely habit two
seven anything worthwhile takes time
sacrifice and ever effort anything
worthwhile
take sacrifice effort and time anything
it takes a while having a nice six-pack
takes a while sacrifice is not eating
the food you want to eat no sodas its
water constantly you know we're growing
your business take sacrifice ninety
percent listen 90 percent of the things
entrepreneurs do who win big no one ever
sees 90% of what entrepreneurs do who
win big no one ever sees so imagine the
recognition you're never going to get
for 90% of things you do no one sees
what time you get up no one sees what
time you go to sing no one sees how many
books you read no one sees how many
calls you make in a day no one sees that
but the same goes for the people that
don't make it no one sees that you're
down working no one sees that you took
the whole day off no one sees that
you're sitting home watching TV no one
sees that you're watching Wheel of
Fortune early in the morning no one sees
that you're not really working that hard
no one sees that only you know that only
you see that but there's a key time
sacrifice and effort there's a patience
that goes with that eight you're a lot
closer than you think you are I can't
tell you how many times I had a person
who he and I were talking and he's on a
verge of giving up he says I don't think
this is for me literally is on the verge
of giving up and we sit down we're
talking all this other stuff and any
decides to stick it out okay and doesn't
quit literally two months later he made
thirty two thousand dollars he see my
giving up two months that he makes
thirty two thousand dollars every single
time I thought about giving up and I
stuck it out the next month something
big happened in my career at that time
it was a milestone every single time I
don't know if it's for me don't
something great will and when I tell you
it's literally around the corner
it's literally around the corner and you
know when it's literally around the
corner right after you're about to give
up don't ask me why it's the waiters
it's just the way it is I don't question
laws there
is loss of the land this is not a law
that a senator or government or a
politician makes this is laws with you
live here you live in Australia you live
somewhere else these are laws that
happens it's laws of life 9 the process
shapes you before it rewards you the
process shapes you before it rewards you
look money can be lost and can be made
you can make the money and lose the
money you can have the nice house won
you can lose a nice s the next day but
who you become in the process of gaining
the house and the car and the growth and
the business and all this other stuff
that stays for a lifetime there's two
things that no one can take away from
you you what's in your belly and what
you ate and what you fed your mind no
one can take that away from you that's
why when you talk to somebody who's in a
military and they get I talked to one of
my buddies who served so many terms it's
unbelievable when you talk to him
there's a certain level of toughness
that you feel when you around him
nothing in life stresses him out because
of what he's gone through when he was in
the military there's a certain level of
toughness that that produces so who you
become in the process by far more
valuable than all the valuables you'll
ever make and ten life is a lot more fun
when you're in the hunt for something
bigger life is truly a lot more fun when
you're in the hunt for something bigger
it just is I think I think this thing is
this thing life can be very boring if
it's the same thing every single day I
remember being in a military there was
some level of excitement about what
could happen next and there was that
exhilaration of something you're doing
because there was a cause it was a hunt
you were after something and it gives
you an energy that you almost cannot
describe either way think about imagine
when you're when you're in a hunt in
life so imagine Red Bull what's another
drink people drink like 5-hour energy or
monsters or some of these drinks so
imagine imagine if you drank 20 Red
Bulls imagine if you drank 20 monsters I
want you to think about that
imagine you drank 20 Red Bulls you drank
20 monsters think about that what kind
of energy would you have it's insane
what kind of energy would have that's
what happens naturally when you're in
the hunt for something that's what
happens naturally when you're in the
hunt for something so as you go through
this list
and you can find this list if you want
the PDF there should be a link on the
bottom somewhere if you go find a video
on my website Patric vide but they'll be
also PDF for you to find the top ten
reasons why you should never give up but
this is something that I every time I
wanted to quit every time I wanted to
give up this is something I kept going
back I've had this for 15 years I kept
going back to this list and every time I
would say you're about to quit it's
number seven you're about to quit it's
three you're about to quit that's number
two you're about to quit it's number
eight you're about to quit it's number
ten stick it out you're about to could
you going through a number five every
single time one of these steps kept me
from not giving up and the next thing
you know in announcer now it's a whole
different habit that we have in and
haven't built the business that we built
now is a very big byproduct of going
through these lists and reminders of
never giving up so question was asked
because we have facebook mentions going
and want to come and show the camera
that we got a mentions going on right
now while we're shooting this year but
the camera here so they can see you know
Mario go in front of the camera in front
of the camera in front of the camera
this is Mario by the way in front of the
camera I talked about we're doing an
episode as well that has to do with ten
criticism ten common criticism
entrepreneurs get and another one is the
one thing in life that's going to be
coming on the video but people asked so
what should I read for ten reasons to
never give up
I will tell you again it's 25 loss for
doing the impossible it's a book if you
have not read it go read it 25 loss for
doing impossible it's a book I wrote
that has to do with three three faces
you need to go through one recreating
yourself identifying your cause and then
going to making history and what is the
mindset behind those 25 laws and you can
find us on Amazon Barnes & Noble ebook
all over the place the link will be
somewhere there go buy the book read the
book post a review on Amazon and private
messaging message me let me know what
you got out of the book on how that's
going to help you out we're never given
up and this is a message that if you run
a company if you run an organization if
you have a team this is a message that's
a timeless message for many people that
you may not know are going through this
right now this is a message to share
with them as well if you haven't
subscribed to my youtube channel this
video may be played on entrepreneur
network a lot of people may take this
video you
subscribe to the channel on youtube
value tainment if it's right here
watching it click on subscription on the
bottom or go on my website patrick way
they'd be calm and subscribe to our
weekly newsletters with that being said
thanks for watching